[Music]
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is on a
wide-ranging diplomatic mission this
week in the Middle East his trip began
Monday in Egypt from there he went to
Kuwait and Jordan his trip finishes with
stops in Lebanon and Turkey Tillerson
announced two hundred million dollars in
aid this week to rebuild Syria which is
still engulfed in a year's long civil
war Margit Brennan spoke with Tillerson
for an interview was 60 minutes before
his trip they discussed his relationship
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
and here is a preview you've said you
had a very close relationship with
Vladimir Putin you've done huge deals
with him photos of you toasting him with
champagne and all that closeness raised
eyebrows it even inspired a Saturday
Night Live skit did you ever see that
skit I did my kids pointed me to it
[Applause]
did you laugh absolutely absolutely I
laughed that loud but since you're
Secretary of State now you've accused
him of violating nuclear arms-control
agreements of cheating on North Korea
sanctions letting Assad continue now to
use chlorine gas chemical weapons on
civilians he doesn't seem to be
particularly concerned about the
warnings you're giving it well I don't
know we'll see if he's concerned or not
what our responsibility is six chlorine
gas attacks in the past 30 days that's
correct and we have called them out for
the fact that Russia has special
responsibilities in our view because of
commitments they made to destroy
chemical weapons and ensure they knew
that there were not that sounds a lot
like the last administration doesn't
sound very different well when it comes
to killing people with chemical weapons
that shouldn't look any different I
think the only difference is the
consequences for it and president Trump
has already demonstrated there will be
consequences does that mean military
action is still on the table
it was in April last year we are serious
about our demands that chemical weapons
not become regular rise or normalized as
a weapon in any conflict Margaret
Brennan is with us now good morning mark
we're named foreign forward to this
interview on 60 minutes what did you
learn about in terms of potential future
air strikes in Syria well that was the
April incident that he mentioned when
the u.s. launched air strikes in
response to the sarin gas attack and
what's remarkable here is he puts
chlorine gas in that same category
saying we could take military action
again and if you look at what you've
been hearing this week there's been a
drumbeat the president of France just
also said I have a red line about
continued use of chemical weapons in
Syria Tillerson also said this week not
only we've seen chlorine gas but we're
looking into reports of sarin it is
clear that despite the Trump
administration's hardline response it
has not stopped Syria from continuing to
use these and it hasn't convinced Russia
to really implement what they promised
they would do here so it's an
interesting thing for him to draw that
hard line well we don't want to give too
much of it
whay so we'll watch on Sunday because I
know you talked about his relationship
with the president Margaret thank you so
much
and you can see Margaret's full
interview with Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson Sunday night on 60 minutes
watch it 7 6 central right here on CBS